so I know we're talking about writing
being very practical and businesslike
but it sounds like you really do have to
be your own sort of you know middle
manager or boss the stress and sort of
unromantic notion of deadlines
how romantic phrase you know deadlines
are the things that may that separate
someone who writes for a hobby from
someone who writes for a living and
those are two very different things
so there is a stress obviously to
deadlines but there's also a relief to
deadlines
in that once you're done with this
project it's done once it shoots you're
you're off of it otherwise you know when
it's your hobby it's your sort of this
this project that you can work on
forever sometimes people do work on them
forever so you know knowing that you're
gonna get to the finish line and then
move on to the next thing helps keep you
looking forward and I actually really
enjoy that you know I one of the things
I didn't like about the YMCA was dealing
with the same issues over and over the
same personnel issues you know the same
two people that you're counseling three
months ago are back in your office and
we're talking about this again the same
budgets every quarter you're putting
them together again it got really boring
I for me I love going full force into
one project and then now I'm done I can
forget about it and I'm full force into
the next thing so that's the beauty of
deadlines right so you're not because I
know I think you'd mentioned about like
you didn't totally want a day job and I
get that because that is a lot of that
same whatever the dynamic is but then
there's new problems with being on your
own because there's like this freefall
sort of that could happen or if you keep
yourself on track which it sounds like
you are excellent at yeah I try to be
yeah you know absolutely it sounds like
it I mean it's that's that's a skill in
itself though yeah I think that's that
is a part you really have to develop and
you have to again I always tell writers
this you've got to view this you know
because everyone sees writing as their
dream job right and they have this
fantasy that they get up in the morning
and they're still in their pajamas and
they're petting their cats and they're
writing for
two hours and it's this wonderful you
know existence and it can be whatever
you want it to be right you're obviously
in control of it but you have to
approach it like a business you're
you're doing it not just because you
love it anymore but also to make money
there's that a whole other component and
if you can balance them right you can
have both you can still love it and you
can still make money but the money part
is a big part of it you know because we
all have bills to pay so if that's not
for you then keep it a hobby you know
and enjoy the process of writing two
pages a day if that's what you like to
do that luxury goes as soon as it
becomes a profession
you